first thing I want to say thank you so
much those an amazing talk and I was
wondering if you could elaborate what I
noticed a lot I go here to EBC is that a
lot of students and young people they're
often desensitized to for example the
atrocities that communism or ideologies
that forced terrorism and maybe it's
some sort of Stockholm Syndrome that I'm
seeing where it's like people are just
there cat they're like trapped and they
can't do they feel in a way they can't
do anything about it and then they start
to like like like communism or they
start to see more socialist or a top
socialist policy that in the end will
get them killed we'll get them hurt as
long as you kind of like elaborate on
what you think can be done about that or
even if something can be done it will
not respect well I think something can
be done I mean I've been trying to
educate people about the horrors of the
Nazi regime and and the Soviet regime in
particular I've concentrated mostly on
those two because but that's good enough
and trying to let people know that it
was through the fault of people much
like them that those systems arose and
and that there are steps you can take to
limit the probability that you would
participate in such a thing and that
those steps are associated with trying
to be truthful in your speech and
actions because the stability of those
systems depends on the willingness of
individuals to lie and and also on your
willingness to take responsibility for
the malevolence in your own heart that
manifests itself in those social
movements and so that when I when I do
my lectures when I do talks like this
when I put them on YouTube what I'm
trying to do is exactly that because
that was the best pathway forward
through such things that I could think
up over 20 years of thinking about it no
one is so habituated to suffering that
they can read the Gulag Archipelago
which is actually quite hard to read
without having it affect them like your
psychopathic if that book doesn't affect
you you know it should if you read it
properly it affects you deeply and it's
not the only example of that kind of
literature so the people who are
habituated aren't they've just been
shown low resolution representations of
things they don't understand that look
vaguely bad you don't know a damn thing
about them and our education system has
done a tremendously appalling job of
educating young people about the
absolute catastrophe of radical left
isn't now it's not much better with
regards to say the actions of the Nazis
although I would say on average people
are more aware of that but they don't
but it's shallow shallow knowledge so
you make the knowledge deep and deep
knowledge changes people and wakes them
up you know I mean the only reason that
I ever got convinced that they're that
good and evil were real more more real
than anything else wasn't because I
learned that good was real that's hard
that's that's hard it's hard to learn
that you have to find examples of
transcendent good you know they're rare
evil all you have to do is look you read
history a bit and read it like it's
about you and there's no way that you
can do that without transformation but
people won't do it it's like you want to
imagine yourself as an arse which guard
that's a rough thing you see because you
have to figure out see young said if you
confronted the shadow which is the dark
side of people the aggressive side the
malevolent side that it it really
reaches all the way down to hell and
Dante sort of was trying to put forward
the same thing when he wrote the inferno
right with the levels of evil right
because it was a voyage through the
levels of evil right to the bottom he
thought the bottom was betrayal it's
pretty good the most the center of
malevolence is betrayal I like that
because to betray someone you have to
get them to trust you and Trust is a
moral virtue right especially if it's
courageous trust because it it puts you
in alignment with other people and
allows you to move forward into life and
if you betray that you really it's like
a
- that it slide knife in the heart
through the back especially if it's
someone who loved loves you betrays you
and especially if they betray you for
your virtues that's a really nice twist
so I believe because I think that people
are capable of good that if they know
enough about evil that that will
straighten them out so but who wants
that you know this is one of the things
I really like about you only he's often
regarded as a new-age thinker that's
wrong he's no new-age thinker he knew
that the the pathway to enlightenment
was barred by the necessity of a passage
through hell and that no one was going
to do that that's why there isn't a
world full of enlightened people you
might say like it was just a matter of
doing nice things following your bliss
let's say however you might put it then
why wouldn't everyone walk up the
stairway to heaven that isn't how it
works that's not how it works at all I
don't think you can be convinced of the
necessity for moral action until you
understand exactly how dark and terrible
things can get and that it's your fault
that they're getting that way who wants
to think that so you can think it though
but not not without it burning you